what's up gamers gamers charge your
brokers because we're about to play them
ultimate bro game of all time very
simply now I'm not supposed to give my
opinion but this is clearly the greatest
game of all time now we kind of meme the
whole thing that it's becoming relevant
again it is actually no no don't leave
no and sad to say I'm not even be
playing my own game shameful so I
thought it's it's about goddamn time I
jump back into PewDiePie stupid
simulator it's been a while it's been a
while by the way if you haven't played
the game in a while it's so easy to
recover your old account just from your
Google account or whatever you were
registered on I got my PT PI account
back I thought I would have to ask you
outer Minds the developers if they could
help me but no it's super easy dude I
gained 7 million views when I was away
what is this pathetic goddammit this is
my room it's so ugly yeah
should we try and recreate the setup I
have here so I'm level 47 let's see have
I been kicked out of the guild I was
part of ok well so the current theme is
sci-fi everyone so for those of you
don't know how this game works it's
basically a youtuber simulator you make
videos which video do I want to make
argue with your intelligent home cyber
dog barks at flying cars that seems like
a great video time travelling comedian
gets copied by everyone that is so sad
clickbait you can click bait now I
didn't know they really
before space-time alright so there's new
items the sci-fi category oh my god what
is that
hahahaha I want it honey so you have to
wait 14 hours are you kidding me
oh good room Felix okay so these are the
other rooms I made duck horn what in the
world what was i building here duck
what's wrong with me my name Jeff
Goodwin
we have Ainsley
this is literally what I said it used to
be that's awesome
well I have all my rewards I have it so
the current competition is high tech we
should make sense for the sci-fi and
right now you can vote for Earth 3018
let's let's check out the best ones okay
that's pretty keen awesome old heart
thing the thing was when we launched the
game we were absolutely overwhelmed by
how many people played it we had this
whole voting system ready but we just
couldn't get the service to work it
would constantly crashing crashing
crashing crash and out of minds the
developer we're literally sleeping at
the office to get it fixed
it was crazy okay I did I did my daily
quest nice I need to add a friend let's
see here Brad boat Oh hahaha all these
people were so supportive of the game so
if you have friends who can receive
gifts which is actually amazing I'm
probably gonna get a ton 3.12 bill yet
but where's el networks that's it am i
part of the network I am they haven't
kicked me out
thank you I'll be so pissed okay time
for me to contribute to my network oking
alright my network has been doing work
so I get shipping time bonus please kill
me is that what the network is called
that's a pretty good name so Top
Contributor of this network are these
people now the question is should I kick
anyone out alright
let's look at this person oh my god what
is that Jesus Christ hey you guys had
tidied a little beauty bye
so what's the leading Network Starbucks
coffee Tube gaming reddit what in the
world pod the pie
what can I join I'll ask to join the the
top Network hi tank alright should we
make a room for the current theme then
since it's been a long time they also
had this new game this new feature which
is called Krrish I may I have the new
headphones they update my character
based on my look all right so this is
Craig you want to get the stuff in the
middle
come on ya son I got a thing damn it
got him no wait do I gotta press again
oh I do okay cool watch beauty fine not
knowing how to play zone game
come online I want the sci-fi reward
there it is
okay I got something I don't want that
that's ugly girls have puggle I haven't
played pug oh my god Edgar oh my god
Edgar Hawaii yeah three times baby let's
have a jukebox now oh you can change the
theme beach lasagna everyone yeah
[Music]
Beach orbits god I would have it with a
big all right
let's design a new room
my god sponsor eagle nice egg dispenser
oh yes of course haven't done this well
that's what the egg is for now remember
man out of minds I'm sorry I'm neglected
the best game of all time clearly
jacksepticeye has more substance i what
the hell no I don't marry this I'm
number one above TC oh yeah and you have
your skill tree and I haven't spending
the knowledge and so long I just want
this thing
let's do fast shipping shipping as a
ride baby it's mine
[Music]
I'm outside
god it's so satisfying
[Music]
there it is Oh buzzer he goes buzzer we
go got'em
all right let's customize in the world
come on I'll be blue alien sweater
all right let's customize the floor we
got this one looks nice
let's customize the walls got this one
looks at big the background oh my god oh
my god
we're living in a a curse we're a
universe a plug birds I feel like with
sci-fi that we should actually be sci-fi
out of all it's change our bench to this
God at rocha t let's give him a little
nope doesn't sit on the pillow god damn
we'll never mind they will have a chest
here where my body will be contained
whilst I live on forever and BR a little
piece I open man so fun to revisit I
highly recommend you guys checking that
as well honestly like I don't minds is
some of my favorite people to work with
they are so thrilled as well and me at
me as well of course how people are
actually getting into the game more more
and more people are into it I think
there's always been a dedicated group of
people that always been playing it but
now the more I talk about it more people
get into it and it is a legitimately
super fun game so let's publish my theme
for high tech if you want to vote for it
go right ahead maybe you want to join my
network called please kill me
Starbucks please let me in I need to
join a network man people 1185 253 what
level am i I need to be the best level
I'm 48 so yeah I live a link to the
gaming description and thanks for
watching see you guys tomorrow bye what
to purse emulators becoming relevant no
no don't leave
no please sponsor Eagle please do
something
yes this game is still relevant
dear me
you